Un problème dont tout le monde parle,
un problème qui vous affecte directement.
Feriez-vous tout ce qui est en votre pouvoir pour arranger les choses
avant qu'elles n'empirent ?
N'en soyez pas si sûrs.
Nous prenons tous plus de risques que nous ne voudrions l'admettre
de passer à côté de ce qui est juste sous nos yeux.
En fait,
nous prenons parfois plus de risques de nous détourner de certaines choses
précisément à cause de la menace qu'elles représentent pour nous,
au travail, dans la vie et dans le monde.
Je veux vous donner un exemple issu de mon monde, la politique économique.
Quand Alan Greenspan était à la tête de la Réserve fédérale,
son travail consistait à surveiller d'éventuels problèmes
dans l'économie américaine
et à s'assurer qu'ils ne dégénéraient pas.
Après 2006,
quand les prix immobiliers ont atteint des sommets,
de plus en plus de dirigeants et d'institutions respectés
ont commencé à tirer la sonnette d'alarme
quant aux prêts risqués et aux dangereuses bulles de marché.
Comme nous le savons, en 2008, tout s'est écroulé.
Des banques se sont effondrées,
les marchés boursiers mondiaux ont perdu près de la moitié de leur valeur,
des millions et des millions de gens ont perdu leur maison lors de saisies.
Au plus bas,
près d'un Américain sur 10 était sans emploi.
Après que les choses se sont un peu calmées,
Greenspan et de nombreux autres ont réalisé une autopsie et ont affirmé :
« Personne n'aurait pu prévoir cette crise ».
Ils l'ont qualifiée de « cygne noir ».
Quelque chose d'inimaginable,
d'imprévisible et de totalement improbable.
Une véritable surprise.
Sauf que ce n'était pas vraiment une surprise.
Par exemple, la valeur de mon appartement à Manhattan a presque doublé
en moins de quatre ans.
J'ai aperçu le signe avant-coureur et je l'ai vendu.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Beaucoup d'autres gens y ont vu un avertissement,
se sont exprimés publiquement
et ont été ignorés.
Nous ignorons ce à quoi la crise allait ressembler exactement,
ses paramètres exacts,
mais nous pouvions tous dire
que ce qui approchait était dangereux, visible et prévisible
tel un énorme rhinocéros gris nous chargeant droit dessus.
Le cygne noir incite à penser
que nous n'avons aucun pouvoir sur notre avenir.
Malheureusement, moins nous pensons exercer un contrôle,
plus nous risquons de le minimiser
ou de complètement l'ignorer.
Cette dynamique dangereuse masque un autre problème :
la plupart des problèmes auxquels nous faisons face
sont si probables et évidents,
ce sont des choses que nous pouvons voir, mais nous n'y faisons rien.
J'ai élaboré la métaphore du rhinocéros gris
pour répondre à un besoin qui me semblait urgent.
Pour nous aider à avoir un regard neuf,
avec la même passion que les gens avaient pour le cygne noir,
mais cette fois-ci, pour les choses qui étaient évidentes,
très probables, mais ignorées malgré tout.
Ce sont les rhinocéros gris.
Une fois que vous cherchez des rhinocéros gris,
vous les voyez tous les jours dans les gros titres.
Ce que je vois dans les gros titres est un autre énorme rhinocéros gris,
une nouvelle crise financière hautement probable.
Je me demande si nous avons appris quoi que ce soit ces 10 dernières années.
Si vous écoutez Washington ou Wall Street,
vous pourriez être pardonnés de penser que l'avenir sera calme et paisible.
Mais en Chine, où je passe beaucoup de temps,
la conversation est complètement différente.
Tout l'équipe économique,
jusqu'au président Xi Jinping en personne,
parle très spécifiquement et clairement
des risques financiers comme de rhinocéros gris
et de comment les apprivoiser.
La Chine et les États-Unis
ont des systèmes gouvernementaux très différents,
ce qui influence ce qu'ils peuvent faire ou non.
De nombreuses causes fondamentales à leurs problèmes économiques
sont différentes.
Mais ce n'est pas un secret que les deux pays ont des problèmes
de dette, d'inégalité et de productivité économique.
Comment se fait-il que les conversations soient si différentes ?
Vous pourriez poser cette question
non seulement au sujet des pays,
mais au sujet de tout le monde.
Les entreprises automobiles privilégiant la sécurité
et celles ne révisant leurs voitures de pacotille
qu'après des accidents mortels.
Les grands-parents qui, pour préparer l'inévitable --
ont écrit leur éloge funèbre,
le menu pour le déjeuner aux funérailles.
(Rires)
C'était le cas de mes grands-parents.
Et tout sauf la date finale inscrite sur la pierre tombale.
Mais quand vous avez des grands-parents à l'autre extrême,
qui ne mettent pas d'ordre dans leurs affaires,
qui ne se débarrassent pas des trucs qu'ils ont accumulés depuis des décennies
et laissent leurs enfants s'en occuper.
Quelle est la différence entre un bord et l'autre ?
Pourquoi certains voient-ils et gèrent-ils les choses
et les autres détournent-ils les yeux ?
Cela a d'abord à voir avec la culture, la société,
les gens qui vous entourent.
Si vous pensez que quelqu'un dans votre entourage
va vous aider à vous relever si vous tombez,
vous avez plus de chances de percevoir un danger comme moins important.
Cela nous permet de prendre de bons risques, pas que des mauvais.
Par exemple, risquer des critiques
quand vous parlez du danger dont personne ne veut que vous parliez.
Ou saisir les opportunités qui sont un peu effrayantes,
qui sont des rhinocéros gris à leur façon.
Les États-Unis ont une culture très individualiste : allez-y seul.
Paradoxalement,
cela fait que beaucoup d'Américains sont moins ouverts au changement
et à la prise de bons risques.
En Chine, au contraire,
les gens pensent que le gouvernement empêche les problèmes d'arriver,
ce qui ne se passe pas toujours mais les gens y croient.
Ils pensent pouvoir compter sur leur famille,
cela les rend plus susceptibles de prendre certains risques.
Comme acheter de l'immobilier à Pékin
ou être plus ouvert quant au fait qu'il leur faut changer de direction ;
en effet, l'allure du changement en Chine est absolument extraordinaire.
Deuxièmement,
que savez-vous de la situation,
qu'êtes-vous prêts à apprendre ?
Êtes-vous prêt à voir les choses
même quand ce n'est pas ce que vous voulez ?
Tant d'entre nous ont si peu de chances
de prêter attention aux choses que nous voulons occulter,
nous ne les aimons pas.
Nous prêtons attention à ce que nous voulons voir,
ce que nous aimons, ce avec quoi nous sommes d'accord.
Mais nous avons l'opportunité et la capacité
de rectifier ces angles morts.
Je passe beaucoup de temps à parler à des gens de tous milieux
des rhinocéros gris dans leur vie et leurs comportements.
Vous pensez peut-être
que les gens qui ont le plus peur du risque,
qui y sont le plus sensibles
sont ceux qui sont les moins ouverts au changement.
Mais en fait, le contraire est vrai.
J'ai découvert que les gens
qui sont prêts à reconnaître les problèmes qui les entourent
et à dresser des plans
sont ceux qui sont capables de tolérer plus de risques, un bon risque,
et de gérer les mauvais risques.
C'est parce qu'en cherchant des informations,
nous augmentons notre pouvoir d'action sur les choses dont nous avons peur.
Cela me mène à mon troisième point.
Quel degré de contrôle avez-vous l'impression d'avoir
sur les rhinocéros gris dans votre vie ?
Une des raisons pour lesquelles nous n'agissons pas
est que nous nous sentons souvent impuissants.
Pensez au changement climatique, cela peut sembler si imposant
qu'aucun d'entre nous seul ne pourrait faire la différence.
Alors certains passent leur vie à le nier.
D'autres gens tiennent tout le monde à part eux pour responsable.
Comme mon ami qui dit qu'il n'abandonnera jamais son SUV
tant que la Chine construira des usines à charbon.
Mais nous avons l'opportunité de changer.
Personne n'est pareil.
Chacun d'entre nous a l'opportunité de changer ses comportements,
les nôtres et ceux des gens qui nous entourent.
Aujourd'hui, je veux tous vous inviter
à vous joindre à moi pour aider à susciter une conversation ouverte et honnête
avec les gens qui vous entourent
quant aux rhinocéros gris dans notre monde
et soyez franchement honnêtes sur comment nous allons les gérer.
J'entends tellement de fois aux États-Unis :
« Bien sûr que nous devrions gérer les problèmes évidents
mais si vous ne voyez pas ce qui est devant vous,
vous êtes soit idiot, soit ignorant. »
C'est ce qu'ils disent et je ne peux pas être moins d'accord.
Si vous ne voyez pas ce qui est devant vous,
vous n'êtes pas idiot, vous n'êtes pas ignorant,
vous êtes humain.
Une fois que nous reconnaîtrons tous cette vulnérabilité commune,
nous aurons le pouvoir d'ouvrir les yeux,
de voir ce qui est devant nous
et d'agir avant d'être piétinés.
(Applaudissements)